Speaker 1: Ronnie Jackson, Donald Trump's
former doctor who is now a congressman,
is using Joe Biden's recent
skin cancer to attack him.
This is really disgusting. These people know no
limits. And we knew that. I mean, Donald Trump
made fun of a disabled reporter, right, early in
2016. And then we knew it was going to get pretty
ugly. Here is Ronny Jackson appearing on Fox News
with Maria BARTIROMO, using Biden's a cancerous
lesion lesion to attack Joe Biden. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Biden had a cancerous lesion removed
from the president's chest last month. The
doctor said that this is a common form.
The lesion tested positive for carcinoma, but
he's okay. But I wonder about the conversation
about his capacity. You have been talking
about the president's cognitive abilities
being a national security risk. Tell us more.
Speaker 3: Well, look, Maria, I'll start by
saying that Biden is the cancer. You know, he's
what needs to be renewed, Wolf, Not the not the
lesion they found. But this is just another effort
from his physician and from his medical team to
distract. They're going to.
Speaker 2: Biden.
Speaker 1: This is ugly. This is ugly, ugly
stuff. This guy's a doctor. First of all,
I know he had skin cancer, but what about his
cognitive abilities? Biden really is the cancer.
There is nothing too low for these people. And,
you know, I criticize the electorate regularly,
let's put it that way. I think this is even too
low for most of the electorate. I know that there
are some MAGA people who will love this and
they'll say, There's nothing wrong. Nothing
inappropriate. There's nothing disturbing
or offensive about this. I know that there
is that group. But the reality is that for
a lot of Americans, even many Republicans,
they're not going to go for this. This is this is
truly not for them. And Ronny Jackson does this
stuff at his own peril. That's my view. If you
disagree with me, let me know in the comments.